JIM THOMPSON: Hey, guys, maybe
a little history of Avere.
We've been around
for seven years.
I've been with the
company six years.
And we've actually developed
a caching technology
to accelerate
network-attached storage.
If you've seen any movies in
the last four or five years,
and some of the
customers are here,
we've had something to do it.
We've been accelerated
the NAS access
from the render nodes,
or transcode engines,
or even the artists.
So We've had a bare metal
machine for a long time.
And just recently, over
the last eight months,
we've developed a
virtual machine.
And we're pretty excited to
have Google part of that now.
And over the last
year as well, we've
developed a connector into any
type of object storage device.
So we're using S3 API to
connect in to any type
of either Cleversafe,
Apple data,
or any software-defined storage.
So we're pretty excited to
have Google part of that today.
So the two offers
we have a Google--
and again, we're not new
to virtual machines at all.
We've actually been
using virtual machines
for a number of years.
Our QA engineering team use
our own virtual machines,
running VMware as a matter of
fact, to do any engineering QA.
It keeps the cost down
for billing out hardware
to do that.
This Google
offering's pretty cool
because the storage
that you can use
is just infinitely expandable.
And the compute engines that
you would use for rendering,
you can expand that out
to whatever you want.
So what we do is we
offer up a file system--
We're a proxy to a file system,
either from an object storage
device or some other type
of NAS, type of device.
So we offer up [? NFS assists ?]
to the clients,
and it could be artists,
it can be rendered nodes,
it could be transcode engines.
And then, in turn, we
talk NFS and the S3 API
back to the storage device.
So the target industries
are media and entertainment,
life sciences, and
financial services.
Like I said, we've been
around for a long time.
We have hundreds of
customers out there.
The early adopters were
media and entertainment,
so I think that's why this is
going to be pretty interesting,
this offering from Google.
So what I'm going
to do, I'm going
to talk about
configuration here.
And if there's any questions,
if I don't cover something,
please ask me later on.
Initially, like I said, we
had a bare metal appliance.
The bare metal appliance was
installed On-Prem, of course.
And the reason for
that is to offload
that NAS product, whatever type
of those legacy NAS vendors
you have.
From the IOPS that these render
nodes were beating the living
you know what out
of the storage.
So we're offloading
all that stuff.
What I mean is that we're
putting the active data set
into our tier.
We're a caching appliance.
We're a proxy of
the file system.
We have multiple different
mediums inside of our devices.
We have DRAM for fast access.
We have NVRAM for writes.
We have SSDs and SAS drives.
So we move data back and
forth between these different
mediums, depending on
the active data set
and what the needs are
from the render nodes
and whatever other clients.
So on the bottom
half of this slide,
you have the
On-Prem storage, you
have your render farm,
as well as your artists.
And on the right of that, you
have the NAS and object store
device.
Not necessarily say that you
would have an object storage
device, but that's
something we think
will be pretty impressive going
forward because the NAS vendors
cost is getting over the top.
On the top, we have the
Google Compute Engine.
So we talked about burst
computing a little earlier on,
and if you don't have enough
hardware On-Prem in order
to finish the jobs
that you have,
it'd be great to be able
to spin something up
into the Google compute.
In addition to that, you can
use Google Storage as well.
But the thing is that in order
to do something-- in order
to really utilize the
compute farm and Google,
you have to be able to
get the data up there.
So what our devices
again-- remember,
I mentioned it's a proxy.
Well, what that means
is if a request comes
in, either the bare metal
machine or the virtual image,
and we don't have it,
it's a cold cache.
We're going to go back and
get it from the storage.
So on the bottom, if that
was a bare metal machine,
if the render nodes make
a request for something--
say it's a new
job, a new render,
a couple shots of
your rendering--
we're going to go back
to the NAS product,
grab it, and stick it in there.
And we're going to
keep it there forever
until there's
competition for space
because obviously the
job's going to finish,
and something else is
going to be more important.
The same thing happens
for the virtual machine.
On the top left, we
have the Google Compute,
and what we've done is we've
utilized their software
to the build a virtual
machine cluster.
We're a clustering solution
of high availability.
So you could build this
cluster out of the 50--
I don't have a customer
that has 50 a cluster.
I think the largest cluster
I've seen is about 21,
but that's not usually normal.
But in any event, you
can scale this cluster
within Google Compute,
depending on how many
IOPS you're trying to drive
with your particular job.
That virtual cluster can also
access the On-Prem storage.
So again, you don't to
copy data up into the cloud
and leave it there.
You can just fire off your job.
We're going to go back
to the On-Prem storage
to grab that data, and
shove it into our cache,
and keep it there.
We're going to
replicate that data
amongst all those virtual
nodes and serve it,
paralyzing it out
to the render farm.
So when you're done with that,
when you're done with the job
and need to output that,
you could write it back
to the Google Cloud storage,
or you could write that
back the way down the On-Prem.
We offer our global
namespace that I'm
going to talk about in the next
slide that kind of goes over
how we can put this all together
in one big globe, so to speak.
So since we're a proxy
of the file systems,
we take either the NFS
exports or those buckets,
from either Google Cloud Storage
or your On-Prem object store
device, and we roll
that into a file system.
We're going to present that,
even an object storage device--
we're going to present
that as NFS or SMB.
In addition to
that, what we can do
is we can roll together
a namespace around all
these different NAS products or
object storage devices, as well
the Google Cloud Storage.
And what I mean is that you
could potentially just mount
slash at the top of the
hierarchy and just cd
and change the different
directories or shares that we
would have representing
these different object
stores, the buckets, or
also the On-Prem storage.
What's really interesting
is that global namespace
is fun and everything,
but I think
what's really compelling is
if you could do something
really interesting with it, like
move data behind the scenes.
And the reason
why we can do that
is because we terminate
the protocols,
but we also offer up
own file system IDs.
Again we have to do that for
object storage devices anyways
because there's no such
thing as file system ID.
Just a common object
storage device, what we do
is, these buckets that
are being presented to us
we gather into our namespace,
we look at those objects
as actually blocks.
So depending on what
object storage device it
is-- it could be a 1
meg, it could be 4 meg,
actually, block size-- since
we treat object storage
device a little differently,
we actually cache
the data differently than
we do in NAS product.
We try to keep all the
metadata for all those buckets
that are active and even
keep the first 16 KF files.
We also offer now, that just
came out a couple months ago,
is we offer up a snapshot for
your object storage device.
So if you had either an
On-Prem of your cluster
that you already have, and
you're accessing the Google
Cloud Storage, or you have your
cluster within Google Compute,
we could offer
snapshots for that.
So you could have versioning
for that particular data
that you're dumping out there.
Since we offer up
our FSIDs, that
allows us to do some
gymnastics behind the scenes.
What I mean by that is
it you're able to do
a move or mirror of data.
And in this example,
what we're doing is
we're actually moving
from your On-Prem storage,
whether it's object storage
or some type of legacy NAS
product, up into
Google Cloud Storage.
So we can do that without
anybody really knowing.
In other words, what I
mean is that the clients
won't know any
different that something
has moved because we're
offering up the FSIDs.
So the FSIDs never change.
So your clients are never going
to see any type of stale NFS
handle or anything like that.
Here's an example of,
we've seen this slide
a little bit earlier-- This
is an example of actually
one of our customers,
and there's two,
there's the one in
media entertainment
and there's another
customer that's
not in media entertainment.
What they have is
multiple locations
that are accessing
either the Google Cloud
Engine for a rendering, or some
kind of compute of any kind,
or also accessing
the On-Prem storage.
And what's not shown
here is that one
of the things that we do
is we eliminate the latency
that your clients are seeing
when they access that NAS
storage or that
object storage device.
So since we eliminate
the latency--
we're a latency killer as
well as an offload engine--
we can place these
bare metal machines
at some other location.
So in this instance, there's
people here in the crowd here
that are using it for
remote WAN caching.
So you could have LA,
Vancouver, New York,
and any other location that
could have these bare metal
machines caching, either
for something that's
stored in the
Google Cloud Storage
or actually caching for your
On-Prem storage that would
be at a different location.
So most of the initial customers
bought the bare metal machine
for just On-Prem acceleration.
And ever since then,
after we came out
with the feature of
WAN caching, they're
actually putting us
at other locations.
So what that means is you could
have people Vancouver working,
which is happening due
to the tax incentives,
or like [INAUDIBLE] faxes
in Quebec, and Montreal,
and everywhere else.
But the storage is living
at some central location.
So this is the product line.
We have the Google Virtual FXT.
And that has a certain
size of DRAM and SSD.
And then we have the
hardware off to the right.
And we have three
models right now,
and the farthest one
the right is the 4850.
It's the highest
performing model
because it's full of SSDs.
The flagship
product is the 3850,
which has a mixture of
SSD, DRAM and SAS drives
for the coldest data.
What we do is, since we have
these multiple different types
of media, we actually
move data, demote it,
promote data back and forth,
within those media types,
depending on what the
client's needs are.
So that in mind, we
also have an NVRAM card
in the bare metal machines.
So some of the tests we've done
with the virtual image that
runs within a Google compute
is that the speeds are really,
really close to the low-end
bare metal machine that we have.
The only thing that's
different is the writes.
It's because there's no NVRAM
card in Google Compute yet.
So we have to commit
those writes in the SSDs.
But other than that, the
reads are maybe 80% or 90%
of what the bare
metal machines are.
So just to recap,
the connector that we
use to talk to the
storage is NFSv3,
or we use the S3
API, which is what
we're using to talk to
the Google Cloud Storage.
We can scale the bare metal
cluster or the virtual cluster
up to 50.
Not that you would do that.
You have to have 150,000 nodes
or something to be able to spin
up your cluster up to 50.
One of the things
that we probably
should have had a slide
on is the statistics.
And somebody mentioned about
statistics a little earlier
on this morning.
We have about 10,000
statistics that we can present.
It's just dizzying, the
things that you gather.
And the reason why we can
gather these statistics
is we're in a data
path, of course.
But we have our head above
water and below water,
so to speak, because we
understand what the clients are
doing and we also understand
the back-end storage device,
whether it's an object storage
device or a NAS product.
So we can tell you what's
happening with the core filers.
We can tell you what
the clients are doing.
And more importantly,
we can drill right down
to tell you what the hot clients
are in any particular point
in time.
We can tell you the rate of
I/O and what that I/O is.
We can drill down even
deeper and tell you
what the clients are doing.
So we can give you a
list of the hot clients,
and we can tell you what type
of activities they're doing.
Are they doing reads?
Are they doing writes?
Are they doing
directory updates?
We can tell you the path
of the file to do that.
You can gather that through
our dashboard, our UI,
or you can actually use our API.
We have an API based
on XML-RPC that you
can use to gather all that data
and put it into any other tools
that you might be using today.